Hey there, Shankar here. The Hidden Brain team has been transfixed by the nationwide protests in recent weeks. The enormous number of demonstrators may be new, but the biases they're protesting are not. In 2017, we produced an episode on a little-known form of racial bias. We decided to return to that episode now as many people are pushing for reforms in the criminal justice system. Please note that the episode includes the sounds of shootings from a college campus, as well as music with violent and explicit language. Here's the episode. On a chilly April morning in 2007, a nightmare unfolded on a college campus in Virginia,
大家好，我是尚卡尔（Shankar）。在过去的几周里，隐藏的大脑（Hidden Brain）团队一直被全国范围内的抗议活动深深触动。示威者的数量之多可能是前所未有的，但他们所抗议的偏见却并非如此。2017年，我们制作了一期关于一种鲜为人知的种族偏见的节目。鉴于现在许多人都在推动刑事司法系统的改革，我们决定重新推出这期节目。请注意，本集包含大学校园里的枪声，以及含有暴力和粗俗语言的音乐。节目这就开始。2007年4月的一个寒冷早晨，一场噩梦在弗吉尼亚州的一所大学校园里上演，
a 23-year-old student acting alone opened fire in a dormitory. He shot and killed two students. Then he walked across campus and began killing people in an engineering building. The sound of gunfire was caught on a student's cell phone. We weren't sure what it was. It was gunshots, but for a while we thought it would have been construction. We heard this horrible scream and laughter. Tina Harrison was a student in the building. So we were sitting in the classroom and basically panic broke out. All we could hear was people
一名23岁的学生单独在宿舍里开枪行凶。他枪杀了两名学生。然后他穿过校园，在一栋工程学大楼里开始杀戮。枪声被一名学生的手机记录了下来。我们当时并不确定那是什么声音。那是枪声，但有一会儿我们以为那是建筑施工。我们听到一声可怕的尖叫和笑声。蒂娜·哈里森（Tina Harrison）是大楼里的一名学生。所以我们当时正坐在教室里，恐慌基本上爆发了。我们能听到的只有人们
screaming, laughter and more screaming. And I counted 24 gunshots within a minute and I lost track after that. I just started praying. By the time the assault ended, 32 people were dead. The gunmen took his own life. The shooting at Virginia Tech was quickly seared into our minds as one of the deadliest mass shootings in US history. Unfortunately, it's been followed by many other school shootings, including the
尖叫、笑声以及更多的尖叫。我在一分钟内数了24声枪响，之后我就记不清了。我当时只能开始祈祷。当袭击结束时，已有32人遇难。枪手自杀身亡。弗吉尼亚理工大学的枪击事件很快铭刻在我们的脑海中，成为美国历史上最致命的大规模枪击事件之一。不幸的是，此后又发生了许多起校园枪击事件，其中包括
killing of 17 students in Parkland, Florida. In all these cases, the news media has struggled to convey the sheer scale of the massacre. There is terror and then sorrow today at the campus of Virginia Tech. There's an act of evil on a scale that we've never seen in this country before. 24 hours after the news began to break, Blacksburg, Virginia, is still in shock from its wounds, and so is much of the time. But even as the country mourned, people began to ask why campus officials
在佛罗里达州帕克兰枪杀17名学生的事件。在所有这些案件中，新闻媒体都难以传达大屠杀的巨大规模。弗吉尼亚理工大学校园今天充满了恐惧和悲伤。这是我们国家前所未见的极其邪恶的行径。在消息开始传出的24小时后，弗吉尼亚州布莱克斯堡（Blacksburg）仍未从创伤中恢复过来，大部分时间也是如此。但就在全国哀悼之际，人们开始质问为什么校园官员
hadn't been more proactive. Why hadn't they spotted the warning signs? Why hadn't they locked down the school after the first shooting of the dorm? At a press conference, campus police tried to explain. We had information from witnesses and the evidence at the scene that
没有采取更多的主动措施？为什么他们没有发现警告信号？为什么在宿舍发生第一起枪击事件后，他们没有封锁学校？在一次新闻发布会上，校园警方试图进行解释。我们从目击者和现场证据那里获得了信息，
led us to believe the shooter was no longer in the building and more likely off campus. Reporters grilled officials who at times seemed lost for words. Can you outline your lockdown policy for the university? Are you saying that do we have a policy to walk down the campus? Yeah, I'm like, when? Under what circumstances do it?
让我们相信枪手已经不在大楼里，更有可能已经离开校园。记者们对官员们进行了严厉质问，官员们有时显得无言以对。你能概括一下你们大学的封锁政策吗？你是说我们有封锁校园的政策吗？对，我的意思是，什么时候？在什么情况下执行？
What's your time right now? It's not in my communications plan. Eventually, the state of Virginia and the university paid victims' families more than $11 million to settle lawsuits. Across the nation, universities cramble to improve their security protocols. Many added expensive upgrades to emergency alert systems and hired new police officers to stay on top of possible danger. Awareness to cold on college campuses.
你现在的时间是什么？这不在我的通信计划中。最终，弗吉尼亚州和该大学向受害者家属支付了超过1100万美元以达成诉讼和解。在全国范围内，各大高校争相改进安全协议。许多学校在紧急警报系统上增加了昂贵的升级，并聘请了新的警察来应对可能的危险。大学校园里对寒冷的警惕。
A subtle fear was in the air, a low grade buzz of anxiety. People weren't taking chances. At schools like Southern Illinois University in Edwardsville, small things that were out of place led to intense scrutiny. His car was discovered, parked in a very conspicuous, very unusual, no parking area at the university here in Edwardsville.
一种微妙的恐惧弥漫在空气中，弥漫着一种低级别的焦虑感。人们不敢心存侥幸。在南伊利诺伊大学爱德华兹维尔分校（Southern Illinois University in Edwardsville）等学校，一些格格不入的小事引起了密切关注。他的车被发现停在爱德华兹维尔大学这里一个非常显眼、极不寻常的禁停区里。
And they found, you know, visible in the car, a note. This week on Hidden Brain, we explore a complicated case that unfolded in the months after the Virginia Tech shooting. It was so complicated that even today, years later, people still disagree about what really happened. At the heart of the case was this question, how can we know, really know, What's happening inside another person's head? Perception, reality and judgment. This week on Hidden Brain. Three months after the Virginia Tech Massacre, an Illinois gun dealer picked up the phone and called a federal bureau of alcohol, tobacco, and firearms. He told an agent that he was worried about a client who was trying to put his guns.
他们发现，你知道的，车里显眼处有一张便条。本周的“隐藏大脑”，我们探讨一个在弗吉尼亚理工大学枪击事件发生数月后展开的复杂案件。它如此复杂，以至于时至今日，多年以后，人们对真正发生了什么仍然意见不一。这起案件的核心是这样一个问题：我们怎么能知道、真正知道另一个人的脑子里在想什么？感知、现实与判断。本周的“隐藏大脑”。弗吉尼亚理工大学大屠杀三个月后，伊利诺伊州的一名枪支经销商拿起电话，打给了联邦烟酒枪炮及爆裂物管理局（ATF）。他告诉一名特工，他担心一个试图购买枪支的客户。
It was the first time he'd ever made a report to the ATF and I think about 10 years of being a gun seller, a gun dealer. Tom Gibbons is the Madison County Illinois State's attorney. Tom says the man who'd contacted the Gundiler was agitated and adamant. He said he needed the guns quickly. And what he was purchasing was unusual. He was buying three low-cost, exact same models of a gun. A semi-automatic handgun, a 380 caliber. The Gundiler explained that the man, whose name was Oletosun Odoale, had purchased the
这是他担任枪支销售员、枪支经销商大约10年来第一次向ATF举报。汤姆·吉本斯（Tom Gibbons）是伊利诺伊州麦迪逊县的州检察官。汤姆说，联系枪支经销商的那名男子情绪激动且态度坚决。他说他需要快点拿到枪。而且他购买的东西很不寻常。他买了三把价格低廉、完全相同型号的枪。一把半自动手枪，.380口径。枪支经销商解释说，这名男子名叫奥莱托孙·奥多瓦莱（Oletosun Odoale），是通过互联网批发购买了
gun's wholesale on the internet and needed him, a licensed transfer agent to complete the transaction. Oletosun's background check was clean, but the Gundiler felt something wasn't right. The ATF suspected Oletosun might possibly be its tropurgisir, someone buying guns for someone else. But Tom Gibbons says police also considered more sinister motives. Having three identical weapons, if a person is going to do something harmful or commit a mass casualty event, having three identical firearms has the advantage of being able to
这些枪支，并需要他这位持牌转让代理来完成交易。奥莱托孙的背景调查很干净，但枪支经销商觉得有些不对劲。ATF怀疑奥莱托孙可能是个“枪手”（代购者），即为他人买枪的人。但汤姆·吉本斯说，警方也考虑了更险恶的动机。拥有三把一模一样的武器，如果一个人打算做出有害行为或实施大规模伤亡事件，拥有三把相同的枪支有一个优势，那就是能够
use the identical ammunition, to use the exact same magazines with that ammunition no matter which of the guns you're using, and of course buying low-cost multiple weapons allows you to have multiple weapons available at a single time. The ATF quickly learned that Oluhtosin was a student at Southern Illinois University. The ATF contacted the local police department and they began to look into it. According to documents later filed in court, the ATF agent also called campus police detective, Rick Weisenborn. The ATF gave the detective a heads up that Oletosan had ordered weapons over the internet. Rick Weisenborn wrote a memo to his colleague that advised them to use caution
使用相同的弹药，无论你使用的是哪支枪，都可以使用与该弹药完全相同的弹匣，当然，购买低成本的多把武器可以让你在同一时间拥有多把武器可用。ATF很快得知奥鲁托辛（Oluhtosin）是南伊利诺伊大学的学生。ATF联系了当地警察局，他们开始对此进行调查。根据后来提交给法院的文件，ATF特工还打电话给校园警察侦探里克·魏森博恩（Rick Weisenborn）。ATF向这位侦探通报了奥莱托孙通过互联网订购了武器的情况。里克·魏森博恩写了一份备忘录给他的同事，建议他们在遇到这名年轻人时
if they encountered the young man. Two days later, a police officer on a routine campus patrol came across an unattended car. He alerted Rick Weisenborn, who went to investigate. Police traced the license plate to Oletosun, Odehwale. His car was discovered, parked in a very conspicuous, a very unusual, no-parking area at the university here in Edwardsville. Police monitored the vehicle to see if anyone approached it. For two days, Rick Weissenborn drove past the car himself.
要谨慎行事。两天后，一名在校园例行巡逻的警察偶然发现了一辆无人看管的汽车。他向里克·魏森博恩发出警报，后者随即前去调查。警方通过车牌查到车主是奥莱托孙·奥德瓦莱（Oletosun Odehwale）。他的车被发现停在爱德华兹维尔大学这里一个非常显眼、极不寻常的禁停区里。警方监视这辆车，看是否有人靠近。连续两天，里克·魏森博恩自己开车从车旁经过。
No one showed up. The detective notified his supervisor. Campus police were authorized to tow a vehicle that had been left unattended for more than 24 hours. So when his car was being towed, it's the police department policy that the car is inventoryed. They take an inventory of the contents and they found, you know, visible in the car a note. It was protruding from underneath the center console.
没有人出现。侦探通知了他的主管。校园警方有权拖走无人看管超过24小时的车辆。因此，当他的车被拖走时，警察局的政策是对汽车进行清点。他们对车内的物品进行了清点，然后他们发现，你知道的，车里显眼处有一张便条。它从中央控制台下方凸显出来。
It had writing on both sides, on one side what's seen like rap lyrics. Turn the page over and there were more lyrics. Tom says they read like this. And you may have to believe some of this out. I lead she a follower. I'm single and not with her, but she got a throat deeper than a sword's follower. For the down on the page was more writing. Tom says these were not lyrics. Send two dollars to, and then it's a PayPal account.
它两面都有字，一面看起来像是说唱歌词。把页翻过来，还有更多歌词。汤姆说，它们读起来是这样的。你可能得相信其中的一部分。我带头，她随从。我是单身，不跟她在一起，但她的喉咙比剑客还要深。页面下方还有更多文字。汤姆说这些不是歌词。汇两美元到，然后是一个PayPal账号。
If the money doesn't reach $50,000 in the next seven days, then a murderous rampage similar to the Virginia Tech shooting will occur at another highly populated university, and then in all capital letters, this is not a joke. Police didn't take it as one. Detective Rick Weisenborn took photos of the vehicle. While snapping pictures of the backseat, he noticed release straps and pulled them to lower the seat backs. He found a water clothing. There was a long sleeve shirt, a short sleeve shirt, and a knit cap
如果这笔钱在接下来七天内没有达到5万美元，那么另一所人口稠密的大学将发生类似于弗吉尼亚理工大学枪击事件的血腥屠杀，然后全部是大写字母，这不是一个玩笑。警方并没有把它当成玩笑。侦探里克·魏森博恩拍下了这辆车的照片。在拍摄后座照片时，他注意到了释放拉带并拉动它们以放低座椅靠背。他发现了一套衣服。有一件长袖衬衫、一件短袖衬衫和一顶针织帽，
with a ski mask. The detective seized all of it. Officers also found six rounds of 25 caliber ammunition in the car. They felt they needed to act fast. It was pretty early in the morning, I remember, and I just got out of the shower. they needed to act fast. This is Thomas Phillips, the third. He was Oletozen Odeoale's roommate that summer. He remembers a loud pounding on the door. And there was about eight police officers standing there.
配有一个滑雪面罩。侦探将这一切全部扣押了。警官们还在车里发现了六发.25口径的子弹。他们觉得必须迅速采取行动。我记得那是在清晨，我刚洗完澡。他们必须迅速采取行动。这是小托马斯·菲利普斯（Thomas Phillips the third）。他是奥莱托孙·奥德瓦莱那个夏天的室友。他记得门外传来巨大的敲门声。大约有八名警察站在那里。
Thomas was asked to step out of the room. Police told Oletozen he was under arrest. Oletozen was wearing basketball shorts and a tank top. He didn't have shoes on. They cuffed him, they had his hands behind his back, and he didn't look my way when he came out, but I don't also think that he saw where I was sitting because I was sitting off to the side of the stairs, but they took him out the long way towards the back where they had a car waiting for him. A search of the dorm room uncovered a camcorder, videocassettes, and a Dell laptop computer. Tom Gibbon says there was also something else, a Jennings 25 caliber pistol.
要求托马斯离开房间。警察告诉奥莱托孙他被捕了。奥莱托孙穿着篮球短裤和背心。他没穿鞋。他们给他戴上手铐，把他的双手反拷在背后，他出来时没有往我这边看，但我也认为他没看到我坐哪儿，因为我坐在楼梯旁边的位子里，不过他们把他带走了那条绕远的后门路线，那里有辆车在等着他。对宿舍房间的搜查发现了一台摄像机、录像带和一台戴尔笔记本电脑。汤姆·吉本斯说，还有别的东西，一把詹宁斯（Jennings）.25口径手枪。
Reloaded firearm. The gun belonged to Oletosan. So let's review. A young man attempts to purchase multiple guns over the internet. His describe is agitated and anxious by a gun dealer involved in the transaction. The ATF launches an investigation. The young man's car is found, apparently abandoned on a campus side road. Inside it is a piece of paper with a threat on it, alluding to ransom and a possible massacre
一支上膛的枪。这把枪属于奥莱托孙。我们来回顾一下。一个年轻人试图通过互联网购买多枪。枪支经销商形容他情绪激动且焦急。ATF启动了调查。这个年轻人的车被发现，显然是被遗弃在校园的一条小路上。里面有一张纸，上面写着威胁，暗示着勒索以及大学校园里可能发生的大屠杀。
on a university campus. When the young man is arrested, a loaded gun is discovered in his dorm room. State's attorney Tom Gibbon says police felt they had prevented a serious crime. So connecting the dots, it became apparent that in fact he was planning. He was, if not planning an actual mass casualty event,
当这个年轻人被捕时，在他的宿舍里发现了一支上膛的枪。州检察官汤姆·吉本斯说，警方觉得他们阻止了一起严重的犯罪。因此，将这些线索串联起来，显而易见的是，他确实在策划。他就算不是在策划一场实际的大规模伤亡事件，
he was planning to be able to credibly threaten that. And he was taking steps, actual steps towards making a terrorist threat. It wasn't long before the news media got a hold of the story. Coming just after the Virginia Tech shooting, the story generated wall-to-wall coverage. Thomas Phillips. For, I'd say about a week's solid, news coverage had its face on CNN, MSNBC, like, you know,
他也是在策划能够进行可信的威胁。并且他正在采取实际行动，朝着发出恐怖威胁迈出步伐。不久，新闻媒体就获取了这则新闻。紧随弗吉尼亚理工大学枪击事件之后，这则新闻引发了全方位的报道。托马斯·菲利普斯。有那么大约一个星期的时间，新闻报道里到处都是他的脸，在CNN、MSNBC上，就像，你知道的，
pretty much any news station you could turn to, uh, that had headline news. And he was either the first or second subject of it. That's all we saw in the news of him what's pretty much. He's a terrorist, he planned this entire attack, he left a threatening note in his car, there was ammunition, he was purchasing guns to either fund this attack or carry the attack out. They showed a table of guns that he never got, but that he wanted to actually buy at some point. It turned out Oletosin had actually ordered four guns off the internet, three of them low caliber guns identical to one another, and the other was a 45 caliber Mach 10 semi-automatic.
几乎你打开的任何一家有滚动新闻的新闻台都能看到。他要么是第一条，要么是第二条新闻的主题。我们在新闻里看到的关于他的基本上也就是这些。他是个恐怖分子，他策划了整场袭击，他在车里留下了威胁字条，有弹药，他买枪是为了资助这次袭击还是实施袭击。他们展示了一张他从未买到、但实际上在某个时候想要购买的枪支表格。事实证明，奥托辛（Oletosin）实际上在网上订购了四把枪，其中三把是彼此相同的低口径枪，另一把是.45口径的MAC-10半自动冲锋枪。
State's Attorney Tom Gibbons. That is a high capacity, certainly a high caliber. It's a scary, certainly a scary looking gun. As reporters pressed for answers, the investigation grew. Friends were contacted, evidence collected. Then police discovered something important. During the investigation, there were computers seized. And something that was located on his girlfriend's computer
州检察官汤姆·吉本斯。那是大容量的，当然也是大口径的。那是一把可怕的，当然看起来很吓人的枪。随着记者们追根究底，调查不断深入。朋友们被联系上，证据被收集起来。随后警方发现了一件重要的事。在调查期间，电脑被查获了。在女朋友的电脑上发现了一件东西，
was a file that he had created in a program called Movie Maker. And what he had made was a video with this language that was found in the note. It was language that read, do you remember the chaos at Virginia Tech? Well, guess what? It's going to happen again in June 2007 unless the viewers of this collectively deposit
那是他在一个名为Movie Maker的程序中创建的文件。他制作的是一个包含便条中发现的这种语言的视频。视频中的语言是：你还记得弗吉尼亚理工大学的混乱吗？好吧，你猜怎么着？2007年6月它将再次发生，除非观众们在以下PayPal账号中集体存入
a total of $200,000 in the following PayPal account. Or else, the number of students killed in Virginia Tech will be topped during the summer school semester at a target university. This is not a joke. Tom Gibbons told me that the language was found in a file that had been deleted. If the video was deleted, how did you know what was in it? Well because nothing is ever really completely deleted off a computer. Our forensic examiners were able to go in, take an image of the hard drive after securing
总计20万美元。否则，在暑期学校学期期间，在目标大学里死于弗吉尼亚理工大学的学生人数将被超越。这不是一个玩笑。汤姆·吉本斯告诉我，这段语言是在一个被删除的文件中找到的。如果视频被删除了，你们怎么知道里面有什么？因为电脑上的东西从来没有真正被完全删除过。我们的取证人员能够进去，在确保硬盘安全后拍摄硬盘镜像，并提取和分析硬盘上保留的所有数据。
it and extract and do an analysis of all the data that remains on a hard drive. On July 24, 2007, Oletos and Odehuale was formally charged with storing a weapon in campus housing and a far more serious crime attempting to make a terrorist threat. The case that was made was effectively that he had constructed this threat. He was planning to use this threat either to act upon it. It was either that or he was trying to extort money. It was a strange charge and attempt to make a threat. But since prosecutors couldn't prove that threat had actually been communicated to anyone, that was the best they could do. I would say that there was only one step missing that we couldn't prove, and that was the actual public posting of the threat. That was the only last piece of evidence that we didn't have that would have made it a
2007年7月24日，奥莱托孙·奥德瓦莱被正式指控在校园宿舍藏匿武器，以及一项严重得多的罪名：企图制造恐怖威胁。所构成的案件实际上是他构建了这一威胁。他计划利用这一威胁付诸行动。要么是那样，要么他是试图勒索钱财。这是一个奇怪的罪名：企图制造威胁。但由于检察官无法证明该威胁实际上已被传达给任何人，这已经是他们能做到的最好的了。我可以说，只差最后一步我们无法证明，那就是实际公开发布该威胁。那是我们缺少的最后一块证据，有了它，这就成了一起
completed terrorist threat. But Tom felt they had plenty of proof showing planning, preparation, and effort to purchase firearms. It's like a conspiracy type of case. It's not exactly conspiracy, but in the same vein, a person is taking actual substantial steps toward the commission of the offense. And by doing that, they are in effect
完成的恐怖威胁。但汤姆认为他们有充足的证据证明策划、准备和购买枪支的努力。这就像是一个阴谋类型的案件。这不完全是阴谋，但有异曲同工之妙，一个人正在为犯罪的实施采取实际的实质性步骤。通过这样做，他实际上是在
attempting to commit it. I asked Tom if this was like someone who does some research on how to hire a hitman, but doesn't act on it. Well, I would like to add more to the person who takes the gun, drives to the intended victims house, and for whatever reason, doesn't get out of the car. But they've taken an actual substantial step toward the act, toward the murder. It's more than just thinking about it. It's more than just a little bit
企图犯罪。我问汤姆，这是否就像某人做了一些关于如何雇佣杀手的研究，却没有付诸行动。嗯，我想补充更多的是那些拿着枪、开车去预期受害者的房子、但无论出于什么原因没有下车的人。但他们已经朝着这一行为、朝着谋杀迈出了实际的实质性步伐。这不仅仅是想想而已。这不仅仅是一点点
of research. There was a substantial amount of work that went into this. So I like the analogy that you have just now, and I'm curious sort of from a legal perspective, what you do with that, because let's say someone does buy a gun and does drive to someone's house and doesn't get out of their car and drives off. And let's say the authorities have some way of knowing about all of this happening. Can you charge that person with a crime? In the murder context, no. In the threatening context, you can,
研究。这里面包含了大量的实质性工作。所以我喜欢你刚才的比喻，我很好奇从法律的角度来看，你如何处理这种情况，因为假设某人确实买了一枪，也确实开车去了某人的房子，却没有下车就开车走了。假设当局有某种方式知道这一切的发生。你能以犯罪罪名起诉这个人吗？在谋杀的语境下，不能。在威胁的语境下，可以，
because they're taking actual steps, they're creating things, they're creating the threat. In Tom Gibbons' mind, a catastrophe had been averted. But had it? To find out, I went to meet the man who police described as a dangerous, would-be terrorist. Stay with us. Today, the story of a young man accused of an attempted terrorist attack, that young man is Oletosan Oduwale. It's a Nigerian name, but it was given to a boy who was born and raised in St. Louis, Missouri. You know, as a kid, me and my brothers and our friends in the neighborhood used to play
因为他们正在采取实际步骤，他们在创造东西，他们在制造威胁。在汤姆·吉本斯看来，一场灾难被避免了。但真的是这样吗？为了找出答案，我去见了那个被警方描述为危险的准恐怖分子的人。请继续收听。今天，讲述一个被指控企图发动恐怖袭击的年轻人的故事，这个年轻人就是奥托辛·奥杜瓦莱（Oletosan Oduwale）。这是一个尼日利亚名字，但它赋予了一个在密苏里州圣路易斯出生长大的男孩。你知道的，小时候，我和我的兄弟们以及邻里间的伙伴们经常在后院玩耍，
in our backyard, we used to go out into the woods and play hide and seek and cops and robbers and all that good stuff and we used to ride our bikes all throughout the neighborhood. All the Tosan's parents left Nigeria and emigrated to the United States when they were young. Tosan, as he was called, was raised with his five brothers in a six bedroom house in St. Louis. He was surrounded by music, lots and lots of music. I fell in love with music probably around seven or eight years old. You know, I grew up listening to a lot of Dr. Dre, Snoop Dogg, a lot of West Coast music. I'm a little bit of like biggy and nods, but majority West Coast music. What Tosin is talking about here is 90 style gangster rap straight out of L.A.
我们会去树林里玩捉迷藏、警察抓小偷和所有那些好玩的游戏，我们还会在整个街区骑自行车。奥托辛的父母很年轻时就离开尼日利亚移民到了美国。托辛（Tosin），正如人们叫他的那样，和他的五个兄弟一起在圣路易斯的一栋六居室房子里长大。他被音乐包围着，非常非常多的音乐。我大概七八岁的时候就爱上了音乐。你知道的，我伴随着听大量的德瑞博士（Dr. Dre）、史努比狗狗（Snoop Dogg）、许多西海岸音乐长大。我还有点喜欢臭大姐（Biggie）和纳斯（Nas），但主要是西海岸音乐。托辛在这里谈论的是90年代风格的黑帮说唱，直接来自洛杉矶。
Young men like Dr. Dre and Snoop Dogg were writing their talent into stardom. Gangsta rap evolved from hip-hop. It's long been controversial because it emphasizes the gangster lifestyle and it times promotes violence, misogyny, drugs and murder. But it's popular and commercially very lucrative. For a kid like Tosun, he was magnetic. He was all in. In eighth grade, specifically, it was in eighth grade. Me and a lot of my friends were used to start like wrapping at the lunch table with freestyle and some I would do the beat on the table and we would just go in a circle with just freestyle,
像德瑞博士和史努比狗狗这样的年轻人在将他们的才华写进明星之路。黑帮说唱从嘻哈音乐演变而来。它长期以来一直备受争议，因为它强调黑帮生活方式，并不时宣扬暴力、厌女症、毒品和谋杀。但它很受欢迎，商业上也非常赚钱。对像托辛这样的孩子来说，它具有吸引力。他完全沉浸其中。在八年级时，具体来说是在八年级。我和我的许多朋友过去常常在午餐桌上开始即兴说唱，有些人会在桌子上打拍子，我们就会围成一圈即兴说唱，
you know, and it'd be like seven or eight of us. And we would do this every single day, literally every single day. And it was just a lot of, you know, profanity, a lot of just, okay, we can finally say what you want to say and give me an example. Okay, so UGK has a song called Take It Off, which was really, really big around like 95 to 98. And so that was a really, really big song.
你知道的，大概有七八个人。我们每天都这样做，字面意义上的每天。这里面有大量的，你知道的，亵渎语言，有大量纯粹的，“好吧，我们终于可以说你想说的话了，给我举个例子”。好吧，所以UGK有一首歌叫《脱掉它》（Take It Off），在95到98年左右非常非常火。所以那是一首非常非常火的歌。
How did you go? You're putting me on the spot. It was Take It Off Trick, Ben, over, let me see it. If you're looking for a trailside, nigga, let me be it. Got the V-12 Bins. Parked outside. Ain't another room left with the girls in my ride. Something like that.
你是怎么唱的？你把我架在火上烤了。那是 Take It Off Trick, Ben, over, let me see it. 如果你在寻找车道上的黑鬼，让我来当。开着V-12宾利。停在外面。我的车里没有多余的空间留给女孩了。差不多这样。
You love this one, you were 12? Oh yeah, definitely. And so this has stayed with you for a long time. Oh, of course, that's one of my most favorite, favorite groups of one house a kid. Tosun says the swearing and tough talk. That wasn't really the point. The music itself was what moved him. Like the rhythm, the bass, the drums, the high hats, it was just like a feel. I think what really makes people gravitate towards music and how it makes them feel.
你喜欢这个，你那时候12岁？哦，对，绝对的。所以这首歌伴随了你很长时间？哦，当然，这是我小时候最最喜欢的组合之一。托辛说，说唱和粗话。那其实并不是重点。音乐本身才是打动他的东西。比如节奏、低音、鼓、踩镲，它只是一种感觉。我认为真正让人类被音乐吸引以及音乐如何让他们产生感觉的是。
And so hip-hop itself, even if you're not in this way from the culture, hip-hop makes you feel a certain way. It makes you feel strong, braggadocious, free, it makes you feel creative. Toaston had a dream that maybe someday he could make a name for himself as a rap star. But when he was 14, his father sent him abroad for school, first to England and then to Nigeria. Now that might not seem the best move for an aspiring rap artist, but Tosun says his Nigerian boarding school was full of kids like him. So I was surrounded around a lot of people from New Jersey, New York, Atlanta, California,
所以嘻哈音乐本身，即使你不是来自这种文化，嘻哈音乐也会让你产生某种特定的感觉。它让你感到强大、虚张声势、自由，它让你感到富有创造力。托辛有一个梦想，也许有一天他能作为一名说唱明星扬名立万。但当他14岁时，他的父亲把他送到国外上学，先是去英国，然后去尼日利亚。现在，这对于一个立志成为说唱歌手的人来说可能不是最好的举动，但托辛说他的尼日利亚寄宿学校里到处都是像他这样的孩子。所以身边环绕着很多来自新泽西、纽约、亚特兰大、加利福尼亚的人，
and London, and a lot of them made music. And so a lot of what we used to do in Nigeria when we were in the dorms is that we would write rap music. And I think it was in Nigeria where I really got, I guess, like creative and better and because we were able to just really lock in. In America, I was only with my friends at school seven hours a day. In Nigeria, I'm with the 24 hours a day for three months.
还有伦敦，他们很多人都做音乐。所以在尼日利亚时我们在宿舍里经常做的一件事就是写说唱音乐。我想正是在尼日利亚，我真正变得，我想，有创造力而且更棒了，因为我们能够真正地全身心投入。在美国，我每天只有七个小时和学校的朋友在一起。在尼日利亚，我连续三个月每天24小时都和他们在一起。
You know, and so it was, yeah, it was, it was where I, I guess, I fell in love with it more. It was when I was in Africa. It was in Nigeria that Tosun made his public debut as a rapper. In church, he went to a Christian school and each Sunday, the entire school went to church. It was a huge church. Sometimes they would allow students from the church to either sing songs on stage or do what a performance is. We decided to do a rap.
你知道的，所以，是的，那是，那就是我，我想，更深爱上它的时候。那是在非洲的时候。正是在尼日利亚，托辛作为说唱歌手完成了他的公开首秀。在教堂里，他去了一所基督教学校，每周日全校都会去教堂。那是一个巨大的教堂。有时他们会允许教堂的学生在舞台上唱歌或者进行某种表演。我们决定表演一段说唱。
A Christian rap. In front of the entire congregation, 2,500 people. When Toaston tells the story, you can hear his happiness just remembering that moment. I run on stage with the mic and everybody's like, and everybody's like praising you and And everybody's like praising you. And then I started rapping.
一段基督教说唱。在全体会众面前，2500人面前。当托辛讲述这个故事时，你可以听到他仅仅回忆起那一刻时的快乐。我拿着麦克风冲上舞台，每个人都在，每个人都在赞美你，每个人都在赞美你。然后我开始说唱。
Nobody heard what I said, but they were going crazy. And it was like, this is a church. I really fed my ego like, oh man, people love me. The people love me, you know, like whatever, it's just church. But that was really really, I guess, a confidence builder, as far as I go, okay, you can take your wraps away from just your circle of friends and actually, like, say them to the public.
没有人听到我说了什么，但他们都疯狂了。这感觉就像，这是个教堂。这确实极大满足了我的虚荣心，哦天哪，人们爱我。人们爱我，你知道的，管他呢，这只是教堂。但那真的是，真的，我想，是一个自信心的建立，就我而言，我心想，好吧，你可以把你的说唱带出你的朋友圈子，实际上，比如，在公众面前说出来。
When Tosin was in his last year of high school in Nigeria, he applied to go to college in the United States. He had only one school in mind, southern Illinois University. It appealed to him because it was close to St. Louis, close to his family, his friends, his home. He was accepted. In the fall of 2005, he started his freshman year. Tosin describes it as a pretty typical introduction to college life, classes, parties, students always moving together in huge groups. In the spring, Tosin decided to join a fraternity. He chose and was accepted by Ayoda Phi Theta, an historically African-American frat.
当托辛在尼日利亚读高中最后一年时，他申请去美国上大学。他心里只有一所学校：南伊利诺伊大学。它吸引他的原因是它离圣路易斯很近，离他的家人、他的朋友、他的家很近。他被录取了。2005年秋天，他开始了大学新生生活。托辛将其描述为对大学生活相当典型的初体验：课程、派对、学生们总是成群结队地行动。到了春季，托辛决定加入一个兄弟会。他选择了阿尔法·斐·西塔（Alpha Phi Alpha），一个历史上的非裔美国人兄弟会，并被录取。
Thomas Phillips met Tosin through the fraternity. He remembers his first glimpse of him because Tosin stood out. He was a little bitty kid wearing a gigantic hoodie and the biggest headphones. Vintage headphones. So do you know, like back in like the 80s when they first had like the home stereo headphones
托马斯·菲利普斯通过兄弟会结识了托辛。他记得自己对托辛的第一印象，因为托辛很显眼。他是个小个子小孩，穿着巨大的连帽衫和最大的耳机。复古耳机。你知道，就像80年代刚有那种家用立体声耳机的时候，
that were like the big gigantic cushion pairs with the metal braces on the sides? Like once you would necessarily wear out in public, you might listen to like these headphones in the comfort of your own home. But something about those headphones and him being as small as he was then kind of stuck out to me. So as it turned out, he was really big in the music, especially rap music. And that was the best pair of headphones
就像那种带有侧面金属支架的大型巨大垫圈对吗？就像你不会一定要在公共场合佩戴的那种，你可能会在自己家的舒适环境中用这种耳机听音乐。但不知为什么，那些耳机加上他当时那么小的身材，让我印象深刻。后来证明，他对音乐非常痴迷，尤其是说唱音乐。那是他当时能找到的
he could find at the time. They gave him the best sound quality. So. The two became good friends. Thomas Sess Tosin was big-hearted. He looked out for people. He often asked fraternity brothers to help him check up on the homeless in the area. He organized campus events, including a speech by former black panther Bobby Seal. And he drew people together with his music. It was music that made him such a good fit for the fraternity. At the time, most of us in the fraternity at least had some kind of musical talent, like if you didn't play an instrument, you sung, if you couldn't sing, you rap. If you couldn't do any of the three, which I can't, then you were either a producer or
音质最好的耳机。所以。两人成了好朋友。托马斯说托辛热心肠。他很照顾别人。他经常请求兄弟会兄弟帮他去探望当地的无家可归者。他组织校园活动，包括邀请前黑豹党人鲍比·西尔（Bobby Seale）演讲。他用音乐将人们凝聚在一起。正是音乐让他与兄弟会如此契合。当时，我们兄弟会的大多数人至少都有某种音乐才华，如果你不玩乐器，你就会唱歌，如果你不会唱歌，你就会说唱。如果你这三样都不会，我就是这样，那么你要么是制作人，要么是
a mixer. Tosin, of course, rapped. Thomas produced. They started talking about making it big. As Thomas describes those days to me, he says it's important to understand one thing about Toeson. His music meant everything to him, but it wasn't him. So one of the things that I did notice was that as much as Toeson, his personality, his actual personality came through in his actions. His music was entirely different.
混音师。托辛当然是说唱。托马斯负责制作。他们开始谈论干出一番大事业。当托马斯向我描述那些日子时，他说理解托辛的一点很重要。他的音乐对他意味着一切，但音乐并不代表他本人。所以，我注意到的一件事是，尽管托辛，他的个性，他真实的个性通过他的行动体现出来。他的音乐却完全不同。
Tosin did relish songs with violent and misogynistic lyrics, but that didn't mean that he was a violent or misogynistic person. One of his favorite groups at the time was P6 Mafia. Who run? Who run? Who run? Who run? I'm not sure if you're familiar with them or not, but a lot of their music at the time was pretty much the version of Rock n' Roll was like six and drugs kind of deal. Eventually Thomas and Tosin decided to move in together. They found a ratty two bedroom apartment not far from campus. Thomas says it was perfect. Meaning like if you want to wrap about you know how hard your life is and how
托辛确实很喜欢带有暴力和厌女歌词的歌曲，但这并不意味着他是一个暴力或厌女的人。他当时最喜欢的组合之一是三六帮（Three 6 Mafia）。谁在跑？谁在跑？谁在跑？谁在跑？我不知道你们是否熟悉他们，但当时他们的很多音乐基本上就是摇滚乐的版本，那种带有性与毒品的交易。最终托马斯和托辛决定住在一起。他们在离校园不远的地方找到了一间破旧的两居室公寓。托马斯说这太完美了。这意味着，如果你想说唱关于你的生活有多艰难，以及你知道你的地区有很多犯罪，你想说唱真实的东西，这真的是你可以做到的地方，而且感觉很真实，因为你不是在录制自
you know there's a lot of crime in your area and you want to wrap about what's real like this is the place that you can actually do it and it feels authentic because you're not actually recording this from You know, you know a nice Apartment in St. Louis some place. You know recording this in a hotel or in a penthouse or a nice recording studio We're in the basement. They're roaches everywhere and we record this in the closet You know what because our studio was in the living room There was a closet in the living room, which was for coats.
你知道的，圣路易斯的某个豪华公寓。你知道，是在酒店、顶层公寓或漂亮的录音室里录制的，我们在地下室。到处都是蟑螂，我们在壁橱里录制这个，你知道吗，因为我们的工作室在客厅里。客厅里有个壁橱，是用来挂外套的。
Like, no one you have guests come, you take their coats, you put them in the closet. We turned that closet into a studio booth. So our microphone was in there, we put foam all over the walls to kind of soundproof it, and that was the studio booth. The apartment became a rap salon,
就像，没有人会带客人来，你脱下他们的外套，把它们放进壁橱里。我们把那个壁橱改造成了一个录音棚。所以我们的话筒就在里面，我们在墙上贴满了泡沫来隔音，那就是录音棚。这间公寓成了一个说唱沙龙，
or, as Tosin puts it, an artist's stand. And so that was how it was. It was pieces of paper and notebooks everywhere in the living room. A couch, a TV, artist then. And so that was how it was. It was pieces of paper and notebooks everywhere in the living room, a couch, a TV, a computer, studio equipment, microphone, keyboard, and that was our artist space. They were experimenting, writing, rewriting, trying to compose songs that worked. They played a couple of gigs on campus. Sometimes they handed out free CDs to get their name out. But
或者用托辛的话说，艺术家的巢穴。当时的情况就是这样。客厅里到处都是纸片和笔记本。一张沙发、一台电视、艺术家的巢穴。当时的情况就是这样。客厅里到处都是纸片和笔记本，一张沙发、一台电视、一台电脑、工作室设备、麦克风、键盘，这就是我们的艺术空间。他们在实验、写作、重新写作，试图创作出行的通的歌曲。他们在校园里演出过几次。有时他们分发免费CD以打响名气。但
money was always tight, and they needed better equipment. Tosin views himself as an entrepreneur. He proudly points out that he came from a family of self-starters. So he says he started looking for opportunities to make some extra cash. He landed on an idea, one that in retrospect might not have been the best. It involved the internet and guns. And so I was thinking, okay, you know, maybe this could be a beginner business where I could buy these guns very cheap from the manufacturers online, have them shipped to a local dealer, and then resell them for retail price and make a little bit of money and we could use
资金总是很紧张，他们需要更好的设备。托辛把自己视为一名企业家。他自豪地指出他来自一个白手起家的家庭。所以他说他开始寻找赚点外快机会。他想到了一个主意，回想起来，这可能不是最好的主意。它涉及互联网和枪支。所以我在想，好吧，你知道的，也许这可以是一项初创业务，我可以从网上的制造商那里非常便宜地买到这些枪，让它们运给当地的经销商，然后以零售价转售，赚一点钱，我们就可以用
this money and buy all the equipment, studio equipment that we could dream of because that was one thing that was kind of harming us our first six or seven months the equipment that we were recording music with was very bad it was just you know the final songs to be a lot of static and it would be just new we needed better equipment what toson was thinking of is called drop shipping it's used all the time in online sales. When you buy a product online from a retailer,
这些钱买下我们梦寐以求的所有设备，工作室设备，因为那是前六七个月一直在伤害我们的事情，我们录制音乐的设备太差了，你知道最后出来的歌曲会有很多静电，就是，我们需要更好的设备。托辛想到的被称为“代发货”（drop shipping）。这在网络销售中经常被使用。当你从零售商那里在线购买产品时，
that product isn't necessarily sitting in the retailer's warehouse. Sometimes the retailer has to order it from a wholesaler. You've paid for a product the retailer doesn't physically possess. Tosin thought he could adapt this model to the online gun market. Buy Guns wholesale and then mark up the price. The basic business idea was by low sell high period. Tosin advertised Guns for sale online. Once people bought them, he ordered the guns from the wholesaler.
该产品不一定坐在零售商的仓库里。有时零售商必须向批发商订购。你购买了零售商实际上并不拥有的产品。托辛认为他可以将这种模式应用于在线枪支市场。批发购买枪支，然后加价销售。基本的商业理念就是低买高卖，句号。托辛在网上发布了待售枪支广告。一旦人们购买了它们，他就从批发商那里订购枪支。
But with Guns sales, there's a catch. Guns bought wholesale must go through a licensed gun dealer before they can pass on to a buyer. That didn't worry Tosin, he wasn't doing anything illegal. He contacted a local gun dealer and asked him to put through the transaction. And so that was what I was doing, you know, I never took possession of those guns, I never intended to, I never did. Tosin agrees that he called the gun dealer repeatedly to ask about the weapons. But that's because he says he had already accepted money from buyers and needed to complete the transaction.
但对于枪支销售，有一个陷阱。批发购买的枪支必须经过持牌枪支经销商的审核，然后才能转交给买家。托辛并不担心这一点，他没有做任何违法的事情。他联系了当地的枪支经销商，请他完成这笔交易。所以这就是我在做的，你知道的，我从来没有拥有过那些枪，我从来没有打算过，我也从来没有过。托辛承认他多次打电话给枪支经销商询问武器情况。但那是因为他说他已经接受了买家的钱，需要完成这笔交易。
So, to recap, we have a young man with big dreams. He's got a budding career as a rapper, an active social life, and a commitment to community service. He's buying guns, but only he says, to sell them and make a little extra cash for music equipment. This is not the picture of a would-be terrorist, but that brings us to that piece of paper that police found in Tosin's car, as State's Attorney Tom Gibbons put it. They found, you know, visible in the car a note. It had music lyrics on one side, but a threat on the other.
因此，总而言之，我们有一个怀揣大梦想的年轻人。他有着蓬勃发展的说唱歌手生涯、活跃的社交生活，以及对社区服务的承诺。他在买枪，但他说，这只是为了卖掉它们，为音乐设备赚点外快。这并不是一个准恐怖分子的形象，但这把我们带到了警察在托辛的车里发现的那张纸条上，正如州检察官汤姆·吉本斯所说。他们发现，你知道的，车里显眼处有一张便条。它一面写着歌词，另一面写着威胁。
It had music lyrics on one side, but a threat on the other. Send $2 to a PayPal account. If the money doesn't reach $50,000 in the next seven days, then a murderous rampage similar to the Virginia Tech shooting will occur at another highly populated university. And then in all capital letters this is not a joke. It would be hard to explain a way a note like this, demanding ransom threatening a campus massacre.
它一面写着歌词，另一面写着威胁。向PayPal账号汇款2美元。如果这笔钱在接下来的七天里没有达到5万美元，那么另一所人口稠密的大学将发生类似于弗吉尼亚理工大学枪击事件的疯狂屠杀。然后全部是大写字母，这不是一个玩笑。很难为这样一张索要赎金、威胁校园大屠杀的便条进行辩解。
But Tosun says the problem lies in one word. Note. What the police found, he insists, was not a note. It was scribbled ideas for a rap song. This is how Tosun says it all unfolded. It began as an idea one night in the artist then Tosun had just finished watching the TV show Law and Order The episode was about some bloggers who live streamed their home on social media So it's me Willow again a lot of you commented on the fight that holds it and I had me as face video home on social media.
但托辛说，问题在于一个词：便条。他坚信，警察发现的根本不是便条。那是为一首说唱歌曲胡乱涂写的灵感。托辛是这样讲述整个事件的发展的。这一切始于艺术沙龙里一个晚上的灵感。托辛刚刚看完电视剧《法律与秩序》（Law and Order）。那一集讲的是一些在社交媒体上直播自己家的博主。所以我是威洛（Willow），你们很多人对霍尔德（Hold)和我让我的脸视频出现在社交媒体上的那场争吵发表了评论。
And so the way the episode started off, while they were live streaming, just hanging out, masked men kicking the door, kiddin' at the girl, beat her up her boyfriend. And then later, they get back on her online page and start a rancid. Tosin was fascinated by the episode. He loved the way it played with viewers. All the way through, it kept people guessing. Were they watching an actual kidnapping take place online? Were they watching performance art?
所以这一集的开头是这样的，当他们直播时，只是在闲逛，蒙面男子踢开门，对女孩动手，殴打她的男友。然后后来，他们重新登录她的在线页面并开始勒索。托辛对这一集着迷了。他喜欢它戏弄观众的方式。自始至终，它让人们不断猜想。他们是在网上看一场真实的绑架案吗？他们是在看行为艺术吗？
Tosun thought the premise might make a cool, spoken introduction to a rap song. And so that was where the idea I was trying to figure out something, I tried to figure out something that would be real to what's actually in life. Like there is PayPal and there is YouTube and there is et cetera there is etc etc etc. And so it was kind of like a copy of that but it's something that wasn't as fake as
托辛认为这个前提可以成为说唱歌曲的一个酷炫的口语引子。所以这就是那个灵感，我试图弄清楚一些事情，我试图弄清楚一些符合现实生活的东西。比如有PayPal，有YouTube，有等等等等。所以它有点像那个的翻版，但它不是那么虚假的东西，
that. Something that was actually real. Sometimes rap songs start this way with introductions that set a scene with lyrics that don't rhyme. That, says Stoßen's friend Thomas, is what they were playing with. You heard the introduction to Nas's, it was written. I haven't, how does it go? It starts off with two slaves in the field, and this is said back in, you know, the slavery
而是真正真实的东西。有时说唱歌曲就是这样开始的，通过引子来设定场景，歌词不押韵。托辛的朋友托马斯说，这正是他们当时在试验的东西。你听过纳斯（Nas）的《It Was Written》的引子吗？我没听过，那是怎么样的？它从两个在田野里的奴隶开始，这是在，你知道的，奴隶制
days. So, and American history. So what happens is that the two slaves hear the overseer coming, and they decide to stage in a revolt right at that point. And you hear the slaves beating the master down, and then you hear the slaves being dragged away once the revolt's pretty much quill at that point. So it's the introduction that draws you in and you hear this violent introduction
时期发生的。所以，在美国历史中。于是发生的事情是，两个奴隶听到监工走近，他们决定就在那一刻发动起义。你能听到奴隶们痛打主人的声音，然后在起义基本被平息后，听到奴隶们被拖走的摩擦声。所以正是这个引子将你吸引进去，你听到了这个暴力的引子
and then the lead song comes on. Tosin wondered whether the demand for a ransom and the threat of a campershooting could make for a good intro. The friends played with the idea and tried out a few things. They wrote some lyrics on a piece of paper. They even made a lyric video where the words of a song scroll on the screen. Toaston Felt it didn't work.
然后主打歌就放出来了。托辛在想，索要赎金和扬言要在营地枪击是不是能作为一个很好的引子。几个朋友琢磨着这个主意，还尝试了各种点子。他们在纸上写了一些歌词。他们甚至还做了一个歌词视频，让歌词在屏幕上滚动。托辛觉得这样行不通。
But some of the lines he wrote on the other side of the paper did eventually become a song. It was called Pop It Mommy Pop It. It's like a club song. It's about like girls dancing in a club called Pop It Mommy Pop It. It's like a club song. It's about like girls dancing in a club. I wrote it complete from beginning to end. The lyrics on the other side of the paper were the ones that Tosin discarded. It was the reference to the Virginia Tech shootings, the threat of a mass killing. When Tosin decided to move back to campus sometime later, he threw all his notebooks and paper and clothes into his car to move them to a dorm. One sheet of paper
不过，他写在纸背面的一些歌词最终还是变成了一首歌。这首歌叫《辣妈狂欢》（Pop It Mommy Pop It）。它听起来像是一首夜店歌曲。它讲的就像是女孩们在一个叫《辣妈狂欢》的夜店里跳舞。它听起来像是一首夜店歌曲。它讲的就像是女孩们在一个叫《辣妈狂欢》的夜店里跳舞。我从头到尾把它完整地写了下来。纸背面的歌词则是托辛丢弃的部分。那是关于弗吉尼亚理工大学枪击案的提及，也就是大规模杀戮的威胁。后来某天，当托辛决定搬回校园时，他把所有的笔记本、纸张和衣服都扔进车里，准备搬去宿舍。有一张纸
slipped under the center console. It was the sheet police would later find in his car. Toeson says the police simply had him wrong. He wasn't a terrorist in the making, he was a student, a musician, a budding entrepreneur. He left his car on a campus side road for a simple reason. He'd run out of gas. He says he was going to get more fuel when he got paid at the end of the week. And that loaded gun in his dorm? Tosun agrees he shouldn't have had the gun in campus housing, but he insists it was an innocent mistake.
滑到了中控台下面。就是这张纸，警察后来在他的车里找到了。托辛说，警察完全误解了他。他不是一个正在成长中的恐怖分子，他是一个学生、一个音乐人、一个刚崭露头角的创业者。他把车停在校园旁边的一条路上，原因很简单。他的车没油了。他说，等到了周末发工资，他就会去买更多的汽油。至于他宿舍里那把装满子弹的枪？托辛承认他不该把枪放在学校宿舍里，但他坚称这是一个无心的错误。
He'd legally registered the weapon and thought that that made it okay to have it with him on campus. Both Toaston and his friend Thomas say owning guns was not unusual in their part of the Midwest. It just wasn't a big deal. One of the things that I kind of want to like make sure that everybody's clear on is that down in Southern Illinois and St. Louis, Missouri area and all that, there was a pretty big gun culture. So when we moved off campus one of the things that he mentioned that he wanted to do and that we both ended up doing was applying for our void cards. the firearm identification,
他这把武器是合法注册的，而且他以为这样就可以把它带在校园里。托辛和他的朋友托马斯都说，在他们那个中西部地区，拥有枪支并不是什么罕见的事。这根本不是什么大不了的事。我挺想确保让所有人都清楚的一点是，在伊利诺伊州南部和密苏里州圣路易斯及周边地区，有着相当浓厚的枪支文化。所以当我们搬到校外住的时候，他提到想做的一件事，也是我们俩最后都去做了的一件事，就是申请我们的 FOID 卡——
that Illinois has, you have to get an ID to own or carry a firearm. Thomas and Toaston both say they had no idea the police were poking around. So when the cops burst into their dorm and arrested Toaston, it came as a complete surprise. So as far as in my mind, I'm thinking, okay, maybe I have a warrant for a ticket or a... I really didn't know what was going on.
也就是伊利诺伊州的枪支持有辨识卡，你必须拿到一张身份证才能拥有或携带枪支。托马斯和托辛都说他们完全不知道警察在四处搜查。所以当警察突然闯进他们的宿舍并逮捕托辛时，他们感到非常震惊。所以在我的脑海里，我想的是，好吧，也许我有一张交通罚单的逮捕令，或者……我真的不知道发生了什么。
And so, I asked them several times that, hey, can I call my dad? Like, I'm gonna call my dad just to let him know what's going on. I can't call my older brother, and they wouldn't let me make any phone calls. He says it wasn't until a couple of days later when Thomas came to visit, that he actually began to understand what was going on. So I picked up the phone and we were talking to him through the glass and first thing he asked me was like,
所以，我问了他们好几次，嘿，我能给我爸爸打个电话吗？比如，我要给我爸爸打个电话，只是让他知道发生了什么。我没法打给我哥哥，他们就是不让我打任何电话。他说直到几天后托马斯来探视时，他才开始真正明白发生了什么。所以我拿起电话，我们在玻璃隔板后面跟他说话，他问我的第一件事就是，
how am I? I said, I'm fine and I'm just trying to figure out what's going on. And then that's when he says, do you remember that night when we were writing and producing and you wrote the thing about the PayPal account and the thing we got from the law in order episode and I was like yeah and then he says that's what this is about. And so when he said that twice he said that's what this is about. Toson Wari they thought he was a terrorist and then came to charge for attempted terrorist threat. I never heard of a charge like that before. You know attempted terrorist threat. I'd never heard of a charge like that before. You know, attempted terrorist threat.
我怎么样？我说我很好，我只是在努力搞清楚发生了什么。然后就在那时他说，还记得那天晚上我们在写歌、制作音乐的时候，你写了关于 PayPal 账户的那段，还有我们从《火线警探》（Justified）那一集里获得的灵感吗？我说记得，然后他说这就是这件事的起因。所以当他说完这句话，他重复了两遍，说这就是这件事的起因。托辛担心他们以为他是个恐怖分子，随后就被指控图谋恐怖威胁。我以前从来没听过这样的罪名。你知道的，图谋恐怖威胁。我以前从来没听过这样的罪名。你知道的，图谋恐怖威胁。
Not a terrorist threat. Still, Tosun was sure the confusion would soon be cleared up. Tosun's my dad gets here with our lawyer, we'll be able to explain this, and you know, and that'll be the end of it. They made a mistake and we can go back to our lives. Well, when the story hit the news, Tosun says everything got warped.
不是恐怖威胁。不过，托辛确信这种误会很快就会澄清。托辛心想，等我爸带着我们的律师来到这里，我们就能解释清楚了，你知道的，事情就会这样结束。他们犯了个错误，我们就可以回到我们的生活中去。然而，当这个新闻登上头条时，托辛说一切都变味了。
They were, they were saying saying a Nigerian citizen, Olu Tosun Oduhale, and making it seem like I was like a foreigner that came over here, just the way I was being portrayed as if I was a terrorist. And of course, my name was mispronounced on purpose to make it sound really, really foreign and just different. And they were not describing me like I was a kid born and raised in St. Louis, Missouri. The news media kept harping on the note.
他们，他们说一个名叫奥鲁托辛·奥杜瓦勒（Olu Tosin Oduwale）的尼日利亚公民，把这搞得好像我是一个从外地来到这里的人一样，我被塑造成了一个恐怖分子。当然，我的名字被故意念错，好让它听起来非常、非常地异国情调，与众不同。他们对我的描述根本不像是一个在密苏里州圣路易斯出生长大的孩子。新闻媒体一直在大肆炒作这件事。
They distorted it, Tosin says. And so yes, when you now paint it that way as a note and violence and guns, it's very easy to make anybody feel like, oh yeah, this was one bad guy, because you can craft information and make something appear the way you want to if you have the upper hand. Tosun says no one in law enforcement wanted to hear his side of the story.
托辛说，他们歪曲了事实。所以，是的，当你现在把它描绘成一张字条、暴力和枪支时，很容易让任何人觉得，哦，对，这肯定是个坏家伙，因为如果你占据上风，你就可以精心编造信息，让事情呈现出你想要的样子。托辛说，执法部门里没有人愿意听他讲述事情的真相。
Thomas Phillips felt the same. After police initially talked to Thomas, he tried to go back to them and explain that they had it all wrong. It's a shame that I can actually tell somebody like a law enforcement official after the initial interview. This is what actually has happened. Can y'all add this to the story and that no one's gonna hear it
托马斯·菲利普斯（Thomas Phillips）也有同感。在警察最初找托马斯谈话后，他曾试图去找他们，解释说他们完全搞错了。真遗憾，在最初的问询结束后，我居然能把真相告诉某个类似执法官员的人。事情其实是这样的。你们能把这个补充到案件里吗？然而却没有人愿意听，
because everybody's minds already made up with what actually appears to be the case. Why did that happen? There were lots of issues. Race, culture, the fear of a mass shooting, and there was the music. After we ran the analysis, we found that in every dimension, rap lyrics were evaluated more negatively compared to when the lyrics were perceived to be country.
因为大家都已经先入为主地认定事情就是表面上看起来的那样。为什么会这样？这里面有很多问题。种族、文化、对大规模枪击案的恐惧，还有音乐。在我们完成分析后，我们发现，无论在哪个维度上，与被认为是乡村音乐的歌词相比，说唱歌词的评价都更加负面。
Stay with us. A few months after Tosin was arrested, a visitor showed up to meet Jeffrey Ordangin, a lawyer who was then a professor at Northwestern University. The man was Toyan Oduwale, Tosun's father. Toyan was unruffled and extremely poised and dignified. Tosun's father wanted Jeffrey to take on his son's case. He was intrigued and agreed. Jeffrey drove five hours south to see Tosun at the Madison County Jail. It was a contact visit because I was an attorney.
请不要走开。在托辛被捕几个月后，有一个访客来拜访杰弗里·奥尔丹根（Jeffrey Ordongan），他当时是西北大学的一名法学教授。这个人是托颜·奥杜瓦勒（Toyan Oduwale），托辛的父亲。托颜镇定自若，极其沉稳且有尊严。托辛的父亲想让杰弗里接手他儿子的案子。杰弗里感到很有兴趣，便答应了。杰弗里开车向南行驶了五个小时，去麦迪逊县监狱探望托辛。因为我是律师，所以这是一次接触式会见。
And that was our first meeting. He was, if I recall, he was shackled at the ankles and handcuffed at his wrists. And he was a quiet, young guy, great eye contact, not particularly frightened, like so many people are in that situation.
那是我们的第一次会面。如果我没记错的话，他的脚踝戴着脚镣，手腕戴着手铐。他是一个安静的年轻年轻人，眼神交流很好，并没有像那种处境中的许多人那样表现得特别惊恐。
In light of the Virginia Tech massacre, Jeffrey says he understood why police suspected Tosin. But he says they should have quickly figured out that they were off track. Once you did your investigation, you should have known that you were off on a fool's errand. You should have known, and it wouldn't have taken too much effort to realize that he was not plotting or planning some kind of massacre, you could have realized and seen very readily that these were lyrics. In fact, there were lyrics on the opposite side, if I recall, of that note, on both sides. And I believe that there were lyrics throughout the car, and his
鉴于弗吉尼亚理工大学惨案，杰弗里说他理解为什么警方会怀疑托辛。但他说，警方应该很快就能看出他们走错了方向。一旦你们进行了调查，你们就应该知道你们是在白费力气。你们本该知道的，而且要意识到他并不是在密谋或策划某种大屠杀并不需要花费太大的力气，你们本可以轻而易举地认识到并看出这些都是歌词。事实上，如果我没记错的话，在那张字条的正反两面都有歌词。而且我相信，在他的车里到处都是歌词，还有他的
apartment when they searched it, they found notebooks with hundreds of pages of rap lyrics. Investigators were unable to find evidence that Toosin had a vile inside. Teachers and students maintained he wasn't threatening. But the prosecution disagreed. State's Attorney Tom Gibbon says, despite Tosin's insistence that what was on the paper were lyrics, he remains certain that they were not. I've probably read at least a thousand pages of his writing to get to know the mind of Old Etosanoda Wally and to understand the difference between the types of writings that he did. And so having and after reviewing all that spending a lot
公寓里，当他们搜查时，他们找到了写有数百页说唱歌词的笔记本。调查人员未能找到托辛怀有恶意的证据。老师和学生们坚称他并没有构成威胁。但检方并不同意。州检察官汤姆·吉本（Tom Gibbon）表示，尽管托辛坚称纸上写的是歌词，但他仍然确信这些并非歌词。我大概读了他至少一千页的文字作品，以便去走入奥鲁托辛·奥杜瓦勒的内心世界，并理解他所创作的各种文体之间的区别。因此，在审阅了所有这些作品并花费了大量
of time looking at it mostly in my free time at night, I became convinced that in fact this was genuinely a crime. This was an individual planning a very serious crime. This was not prosecuting someone for writing lyrics. This was prosecuting somebody for all of the substantial steps that he had taken toward very serious crimes and potentially a mass casualty event. So now we have two different stories. One is a tale of a potential terrorist plotting a campus massacre. Another is a story of a young man who has unlawfully stored a gun at his university, but otherwise has done little wrong.
时间去研究它们之后——主要是在我晚上的空闲时间里，我开始确信，这实际上确实是一起犯罪。这是一个正在策划极其严重的犯罪的个人。这并不是在起诉某人写歌词。这是在起诉某人为走向极其严重的罪行以及潜在的大规模伤亡事件所采取的所有实质性步骤。所以现在我们有两个不同的故事。一个是关于一个潜在的恐怖分子在策划校园大屠杀的故事。另一个则是一个年轻人错误地在大学里藏了一把枪，但除此之外并没有做错什么的故事。
It would be up to a jury to decide which story was the truthful one and how to understand those words written on that piece of paper. But before we head to trial, I want to introduce you to one more person. My name is Sharis Kubran, and I'm a professor of criminology law and society at the University of California Irvine. Sharis was called as an expert for the defense in Tosun's case, in part because of some interesting research she's done. She was noticing a large number of prosecutions that were introducing rap lyrics in court. She had a basic question. Are violent lyrics perceived as more threatening, more dangerous, more literal, more in need of regulation, when they are described as rap compared to other music
哪一个故事才是真实的，以及如何理解写在那张纸上的那些字眼，将由陪审团来决定。但在我们开庭审判之前，我想向大家介绍另一个人。我叫沙里斯·库布兰（Sharis Kubran），我是加州大学尔湾分校的犯罪学、法律与社会学教授。沙里斯作为辩方专家证人被请到了托辛的案子中，部分原因是因为她做过的一些有趣的研究。她注意到有大量的刑事案件在法庭上引入了说唱歌词。她有一个基本的问题。当暴力歌词被描述为说唱时，与其它音乐流派相比，它们是否会被认为更具威胁性、更危险、更字面化、更需要受到监管？
genres? This question, she felt, was intricately linked to the outcomes of criminal cases. Because prosecutors are using rap lyrics as evidence in these criminal trials, I felt this raises a whole host of questions about whether prosecutors, judges, jurors may be relying on perception and stereotype about rappers and rap music in their interpretation and evaluation of the lyrics. So Sharers devised a study. She pulled lyrics from a 1960s folk song. We identified a set of violent lyrics. It was actually lyrics from this song, Bad Man's Blunder.
她觉得，这个问题与刑事案件的结果有着千丝万缕的联系。由于检察官在这些刑事审判中将说唱歌词用作证据，我觉得这引发了一系列的问题：关于检察官、法官、陪审团在对歌词进行解释和评估时，是否可能依赖于对说唱歌手和说唱音乐的看法和刻板印象。于是沙里斯设计了一项研究。她从一首20世纪60年代的民歌中提取了歌词。我们确定了一组暴力歌词。实际上这首歌的歌词来自《恶棍的失误》（Bad Man's Blunder）。
And it's a Kingston trio folk group from the 60s. And the lyrics go something like this. Well, early one evening, I was rolling around. I was feeling kind of mean. I shot a deputy down. Strolling on home and I went to bed. Well, I laid my pistol up under my head. Well, early in the morning about the break of day,
这是60年代的一个名叫金斯顿三重唱（Kingston trio）的民谣乐队的歌词。歌词大概是这样的：嗯，一天傍晚，我在四处闲逛。我当时感觉有点不怀好意。我一枪打倒了一个副警长。溜达着回了家，然后我上床睡觉。嗯，我把手枪枕在我的头底下。嗯，清晨破晓时分，
I figured it was time to make a getaway. Step and write along, but I was step into slow, got surrounded by a sheriff down in Mexico. Well early in the morning by the break of day I figured it was time to make it get away. Step and write along but I was step and too slow got surrounded by a sheriff down in Mexico. So we took this set of violent lyrics and we told participants in our experiment that they were either rap lyrics or country music lyrics. Sharris then asked them how threatening and offensive they perceived the lyrics to be
我觉得是时候逃跑了。大步流星地走着，但我走得太慢了，在墨西哥被一个治安官包围了。嗯，清晨破晓时分，我觉得是时候逃跑了。大步流星地走着，但我走得太慢了，在墨西哥被一个治安官包围了。于是我们采用了这组含有暴力倾向的歌词，并告诉我们实验的参与者，这些要么是说唱歌词，要么是乡村音乐歌词。接着，沙里斯询问他们认为这些歌词有多大的威胁性和冒犯性，
and whether they felt the lyrics should be regulated. And after we ran the analysis, we found that in every dimension, rap lyrics were evaluated more negatively compared to when the lyrics were perceived to be country. Charis then replicated the study. Again, she didn't play songs for volunteers, she just printed out the lyrics from a Johnny Cash song. Um, called Boyn M. Sue.
以及他们是否觉得这些歌词应该受到监管。在我们完成分析后，我们发现，无论在哪个维度上，与被认为是乡村音乐的歌词相比，说唱歌词的评价都更加负面。然后沙里斯重复了这项研究。同样，她没有给志愿者播放歌曲，她只是打印出了一首约翰尼·卡什（Johnny Cash）歌曲的歌词。呃，这首歌叫《名叫苏的男孩》（Boy Named Sue）。
But I busted a chair right across his teeth and we crashed through the wall and into the street. And by the way, Johnny Cash gets invoked a lot because everyone knows his song, I shot a man in Reno just to watch him die. And so Johnny Cash gets kind of invoked like, well, why can Johnny Cash say lyrics like that? Where he's shooting a man in Reno and there's other violence, but when rappers do it, it's seen as literal. But anyway, we selected these lyrics from a boy named Sue. Well, I hit him hard right between the eyes, and he went down, but to my surprise.
但我一椅子砸在他牙齿上，我们撞穿了墙壁，冲到了街上。顺便说一句，约翰尼·卡什经常被提及，因为每个人都知道他的歌词：“我在里诺枪杀了一个人，只是为了看他死去。”所以约翰尼·卡什总被这样引述：嗯，为什么约翰尼·卡什可以说这样的歌词？他在歌里枪杀了一个人，里面还有其他的暴力内容，但当说唱歌手这样做时，就被视为是字面意思。不过不管怎样，我们从《名叫苏的男孩》中挑选了这些歌词。嗯，我狠狠地打了他双眼之间，他倒下了，但令我惊讶的是，
He came up with a knife and cut off a piece of my ear, but I busted a chair right across his teeth, and we crashed through the wall and into the street, kicking in a gouging in the mud and the blood in the beer. I tell you, I've pulled tough her men, but I really can't remember when. It kicked like a mule, and it bit like a crocodile. We found that those people who thought that those were rap lyrics were much more likely to evaluate them negatively on all those dimensions compared to those participants in our study who thought they were country. As a criminologist, Sharari says her results are troubling.
他掏出一把刀，割掉了我的一只耳朵，但我一椅子砸在他牙齿上，我们撞穿了墙壁，冲到了街上，在泥土、血水和啤酒中又踢又戳。我跟你说，我拉扯过很多硬汉，但我真的记不清是什么时候了。它像骡子一样踢人，像鳄鱼一样咬人。我们发现，那些认为这些是说唱歌词的人，与我们研究中那些认为这是乡村音乐的参与者相比，更有可能在所有这些维度上对它们做出负面评价。作为一名犯罪学家，沙里斯说她的结果令人不安。
I am not necessarily advocating to not find people guilty of a crime that they've committed. What I am advocating for is the use of proper techniques and proper evidence to arrive at that decision. Right now prosecutors are relying too heavily on a form of artistic expression that is fictional, that has a lot of artistic conventions knowing full well that the vast majority of jurors and judges don't really know what the artistic conventions of rat music are.
我并不是一定要主张不去判定犯了罪的人有罪。我所主张的是使用正确的技巧和正确的证据来得出那个决定。现在，检察官过分依赖一种属于虚构的、具有许多艺术惯例的艺术表达形式，他们明明知道绝大多数陪审团和法官并不真正了解说唱音乐的艺术惯例是什么。
The prosecutors in this sense are taking shortcuts and it's at the expense of people's lives. And by the way, no other form of artistic expression is treated this way in the courts, because it's not as if rock musicians and heavy metal musicians and punk musicians are having their lyrics introduced as evidence against them. This is happening only for rappers and rap music. On October 18, 2011, in Madison County, Illinois, Oluhtosan Oluwale's trial began. Jeffrey Ordangan says, things went wrong from the start. Oluhtosan Oluwale was a very dark skinned Nigerian young man,
从这个意义上说，检察官是在走捷径，而这是以牺牲人们的生命为代价的。顺便说一句，法庭上没有其他任何艺术表达形式受到这样的对待，因为这并不是说摇滚乐手、重金属乐手和朋克乐手的歌词会被当作不利于他们的证据引入法庭。这种情况只发生在说唱歌手和说唱音乐身上。2011年10月18日，在伊利诺伊州麦迪逊县，奥鲁托辛·奥杜瓦勒的审判开始了。杰弗里·奥尔丹根说，事情从一开始就出错了。奥鲁托辛·奥杜瓦勒是一个皮肤非常黝黑的尼日利亚年轻男子，
whose interest was rap and the whole defense was centered around rap. The jury was all white, overwhelmingly rural, and the average age was in the 40s and 50s. So if you put that profile together, a 50-year-old white rural juror trying to understand our defense who've none of them, if I recall, had ever listened with any frequency to rap music. Some of them did not know what it was, but this was the jury that we ended up with. And so that was a problem. Tom Gibbons did not argue the case, but supervised the attorneys who did.
他的兴趣是说唱，整个辩护也是围绕着说唱展开的。陪审团全都是白人，绝大多数来自农村，平均年龄在40到50岁之间。所以如果你把这个组合拼凑起来，一个50岁的白人乡村陪审团成员试图理解我们的辩护，如果我没记错的话，他们当中没有一个人曾经常常听过说唱音乐。他们当中有些人甚至不知道那是什么，但这却是我们最终得到的陪审团。所以这就是个问题。汤姆·吉本没有亲自出庭辩护，而是监督负责辩护的律师。
He believes they acted with care and caution. I wanted to make absolutely sure that we weren't using the authority of the State's Attorney's Office to prosecute somebody for their thoughts, to prosecute somebody for, in this case, rap lyrics. That's not an appropriate use of the power of a prosecutor's office and the power of law enforcement. Again, much of the attention was focused on that piece of paper that police found in Tosun's car. Tom Gibbon says the defense argued strenuously
他相信他们的行动是小心谨慎的。我想要绝对确保我们没有动用州检察官办公室的权力去起诉某人的思想，去起诉某人——在本案中是因为说唱歌词。这不是检察官办公室权力和执法权力的恰当使用方式。同样，大部分的注意力都集中在那张警察在托辛车里发现的纸条上。汤姆·吉本说，辩方极力主张
that the writing was rap lyrics. Although I have to tell you, one of his lawyers tried to rap the words in this note in trial and it was a miserable failure because these are not rap lyrics. To this comment, Tosin just shakes his head. He admits the lyrics were not very good, which is why he didn't end up using them in a song. But they were still rap. They didn't want to tell people it was rap music, they wanted to say it was a note. So they didn't show where it rhymed,
这些字句是说唱歌词。虽然我必须告诉你，他的其中一位律师在审判中试图把这张纸条里的词句说唱出来，结果却是一场惨败，因为这些根本不是说唱歌词。听到这个评论，托辛只是摇了摇头。他承认这些歌词确实写得不太好，这也是为什么他最后没有把它们用在歌曲里的原因。但它们依然是说唱。他们不想告诉人们那是说唱音乐，他们想说那只是一张字条。所以他们没有展示哪里押了韵，
where it actually rhymed. If you don't know rap music, and I just give you that sentence, where can you make it rhyme? It doesn't look like a rhyme. If this account doesn't reach 50,000, seven days, get ready for a murderous rampage. Simulator to the VT shooting will occur at A-Nother.
哪里真正押了韵。如果你不懂说唱音乐，而我只给你那个句子，你在哪里能让它押韵？它看起来一点也不像押韵。如果这个账户在七天内没有达到五万，准备好迎接一场暴力的狂欢吧。类似于VT枪击案的事情将发生在另一个。
How he populated university and this is not a joke. So if you don't know rap music, you won't be able to piece that together. Majority of Southern Illinois Midwestern people that are 40, 50, 60 years old, prosecutors, police officers, they don't know how to break down rat music or anything. So when I said, Hey, that was like a small piece of like a rat first that we didn't even want to use.
他人口稠密的大学，这不是在开玩笑。所以如果你不懂说唱音乐，你就无法把这些拼凑起来。伊利诺伊州南部和中西部的绝大多数40岁、50岁、60岁的人，检察官、警察，他们不知道如何拆解说唱音乐或任何东西。所以当我说，嘿，那只是一小段我们甚至不想用的说唱主歌时，
They're like, get out of here. He's lying. After a five day trial, the jury returned its verdict guilty. State's attorney Tom Gibbons. The jury convicted Mr. Odo Wally. They took all the evidence into account. They deliberated for I don't recall the amount of time. I think it was a couple hours at least.
他们就像是在说，滚开吧。他在撒谎。经过五天的审判，陪审团做出了有罪的裁决。州检察官汤姆·吉本。陪审团判定奥杜瓦勒先生有罪。他们考虑了所有的证据。他们进行了审议，具体时间我记不清了。我想至少有几个小时吧。
And they returned a verdict of guilty on both counts. And he was sentenced to five years in the Department of Corrections on the attempted terrorist threat and a year in the Madison County Jail on the unauthorized possession of a weapon based on the level of the offense. Jeffrey Ordangon says the trial was a disaster. It was a first amendment train wreck in my view. Jeffrey sees two flaws in the prosecution's case. First, they criminalized speech.
他们对两项指控都做出了有罪的裁决。他被判处在惩教署服刑五年，罪名是图谋恐怖威胁，并在麦迪逊县监狱服刑一年，罪名是根据犯罪情节非法持有武器。杰弗里·奥尔丹根说，这场审判是一场灾难。依我之见，这是一场宪法第一修正案的灾难。杰弗里认为控方的案件有两个缺陷。首先，他们将言论刑事犯罪化。
By taking a work of art, it's something that was intended as a work of art, something that was intended as a work of art, and distorted it into criminal intent. Second, he says, they criminalized thought. By criminalizing thought, what I mean is, we need to charge this man with a crime because for all we know, he was thinking about acting on what we surmise were evil intense, even though we have no evidence that he intended to communicate that thought. Tosun says his worst moment came after the trial
通过将一件艺术品——原本意在作为艺术品的东西，原本意在作为艺术品的东西——歪曲成犯罪意图。其次，他说，他们将思想刑事犯罪化。通过将思想刑事犯罪化，我的意思是，我们需要以犯罪罪名起诉这个人，因为据我们所知，他当时正在考虑将我们推测的邪恶意图付诸行动，尽管我们没有任何证据表明他打算传达那种思想。托辛说，他最糟糕的时刻是在审判之后
at the Graham Correctional Center. They strip you naked, they tell you to bend over, they make sure you're not sneaking in any weapons, just a very degrading process. And then when they put me in a cell and then they lock the door and then you hear the clink. And it's a small cell, it's like 5x9. There's two metal bunk beds in there and it's you and another guy. And you just feel so claustrophobic, but you can't leave.
在格雷姆惩教中心（Graham Correctional Center）。他们剥光你的衣服，叫你弯下腰去，确保你没有偷运任何武器，这绝对是一个极具侮辱性的过程。然后当他们把我关进牢房，锁上门，接着你听到咔哒一声。那是一个很小的牢房，大约5乘9英尺。里面有两张金属双层床，里面只有你和另一个人。你会感到无比的幽闭恐惧，但你却无法离开。
Tosun says it felt like being punched in the gut. Jeffrey Ardangan appealed the conviction. A year and a half later, the case came before an appellate court. The conviction for the terrorist charge was overturned. The court said, in the absence of sufficient evidence that the defendant had taken a substantial step toward making a terrorist threat, his writings, as a warrant as they might be, amount to mere thoughts. Since Stoson's case went to trial, there have been many other cases in which rap artists have had their lyrics introduced as evidence in criminal proceedings.
托辛说，那感觉就像腹部挨了一拳。杰弗里·奥尔丹根对定罪提出了上诉。一年半后，该案提交到了上诉法院。关于恐怖主义指控的定罪被推翻了。法院表示，在缺乏充分证据证明被告已采取实质性步骤去发出恐怖威胁的情况下，他的文字——无论看起来多么令人担忧——都只属于纯粹的思想。自从托辛的案子开庭审判以来，还有许多其他案件中，说唱歌手的歌词被作为证据引入了刑事诉讼程序。
Criminologist, Charis Cubran. Not a lot of people know that this is happening. I don't think we quite understand the implications of using rap lyrics as evidence. And what that means for defendants. Like, can they get a fair trial? Can we ensure that their First Amendment rights are protected when these lyrics have the potential to bias jurors? When Ahmed is home in New Jersey, Oletos in Oduhale was 31 years old. He says the trial, the conviction, the prison time, he's put all of that behind him.
犯罪学家沙里斯·库布兰。没有多少人知道这件事正在发生。我认为我们并不完全理解将说唱歌词用作证据的含义。这对被告意味着什么。比如，他们能得到公正的审判吗？当这些歌词有可能使陪审团产生偏见时，我们能否确保他们的第一修正案权利得到保护？当奥鲁托辛·奥杜瓦勒回到新泽西州的家中时，他已经31岁了。他说，这场审判、定罪、牢狱之灾，他已经把这一切都抛在脑后了。
But one thing still upsets him. Having lyrics he considers embarrassingly bad attached to his name. There's a lot of stuff that you will never hear, that you will never see, because I either didn't think it was good, or I didn't think it would be received well. This was supposed to be one of those things that the world was never supposed to see or hear. Every artist, aspiring or well-established, knows what it's like to try something here. Every artist, aspiring or well-established, knows what it's like to try something and then toss it aside.
但有一件事仍然让他感到不安。那就是让那些他认为烂到令人尴尬的歌词跟他的名字绑在一起。有很多东西你永远都不会听到，你永远都不会看到，因为要么我觉得它不够好，要么我觉得它不会受欢迎。这本该是那种世人永远不该看到或听到的一类东西。每一个雄心勃勃或已经成名的艺术家，都知道尝试某个东西然后将其抛弃是什么感觉。
The drawings are skew, the photograph is blurry, the verses don't rhyme. The cutting-room floor is littered with false starts and failed attempts, but these dead ends and errors are essential to the artistic process. Toaston never ended up becoming a rap star. He's still a musician, but these days he's more focused on his career in real estate. He's still buying low and selling high. Toaston recently co-founded a real estate hedge fund in Atlanta.
画作歪歪扭扭，照片模糊不清，诗句不押韵。剪辑室的地上到处都是错误的开端和失败的尝试，但这些死胡同和错误对于艺术创作过程来说是必不可少的。托辛最终并没有成为说唱巨星。他依然是个音乐人，但如今他更专注于房地产事业。他依然在低买高卖。托辛最近在亚特兰大共同创立了一家房地产对冲基金。
He now has bachelor's degree in business management, and he's hoping to start a family one day. Some of Tosin's music did find the spotlight. People spent hours pouring over his songs, analyzing his words. But like others before him, Tosin discovered that the artist doesn't always control how his creations are understood. Sometimes, the stuff on the cutting room floor ends up being your legacy. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Reina Cohen, Jenny Schmitt and Tara Boyard. Our team includes Pat Shah, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarell and Kat Schuchner. Original music for this episode was composed by Ram Tina Rablewicz.
他现在拥有企业管理学士学位，并且希望有一天能组建一个家庭。托辛的一些音乐确实进入了聚光灯下。人们花了好几个小时仔细研读他的歌曲，分析他的字句。但和前人一样，托辛发现，艺术家并不总是能掌控自己的创作被如何理解。有时候，剪辑室地上的那些废料最终会成为你的遗产。本期《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）由雷娜·科恩（Reina Cohen）、珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmitt）和塔拉·博亚德（Tara Boyard）制作。我们的团队包括帕特·沙阿（Pat Shah）、托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarell）和凯特·舒赫纳（Kat Schuchner）。本集的原创音乐由拉姆·蒂娜·拉布利维奇（Ram Tina Rablewicz）创作。
The song you're hearing was written and performed by Oletosin Odewale. It's called Love Me. This week, we're saying goodbye to our intern, Lu-Sheik Waba. Lu-Sheik has been a vital member of the team from the moment she arrived. She's a stellar audio producer and has helped us build an archive that we can draw on for years to come. She's going to be deeply missed. Thank you, Lushik, for all that you brought to Hidden Brain. Our Ronsang hero this week is Mary Glendini. Mary is a research librarian at NPR and she played a crucial role in tracking down information for the story. Mary and her team are fact checkers, detectives,
你刚才听到的这首歌由奥鲁托辛·奥杜瓦勒创作并演唱。它叫《爱我》（Love Me）。本周，我们要向实习生卢谢克·瓦巴（Lu-Sheik Waba）道别。卢谢克从来到这里的第一天起，就一直是团队中至关重要的一员。她是一位杰出的音频制作人，并帮助我们建立了一个资料库，我们将在未来几年里从中受益。我们会深深地怀念她。谢谢你，卢谢克，感谢你为《隐藏的大脑》所带来的一切。我们本周的幕后英雄是玛丽·格伦迪尼（Mary Glendini）。玛丽是 NPR 的研究图书管理员，她在为这个故事搜寻信息的过程中发挥了至关重要的作用。玛丽和她的团队是事实核查员、侦探、
masters of the archives, and data experts. Thank you, Mary, and all the researchers at NPR for your very hard work. For more hidden brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like this episode, please share it with a friend. I'm Sean Carvedantum, and this is NPR. Please share it with a friend.
档案大师和数据专家。谢谢你，玛丽，也谢谢 NPR 的所有研究人员，感谢你们的辛勤工作。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》内容，您可以在 Facebook 和 Twitter 上关注我们。如果您喜欢这一集，请与朋友分享。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam），这是 NPR。请与朋友分享。
I'm Shankar Vedantum, and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是 NPR。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。